SHRINKER ANDNING
GOAL IN FOUR STRAIGHT GAMES!
AND 1-0
UP A RINK WIDE PASS TO THE
BACKDOOR AND HOW ABOUT
NATE SCHMIDT!
WIRES IT FROM THE LINE!
THE JETS GO BANG-BANG!
AND IT IS 2-0!O HIM AND
HAS A MAN TO FIND THE OPEN MAN.
WE HAVE
THIS PENALTY KILL A SOURCE OF
MOMENTUM FOR THE LAST WEEK,
WEEKEKM
DUBOIS.
FROM THE TOP OF THE CREASE TO
PETRY ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
ANDERSON TAKES THE YOU CAN
COUNT ON STEWS STEWS's TEAM
WON'T GIVE
>> Dennis: CLEAN
FACE-OFF WIN.
ALL FIVE GUYS ON T T
>> Dennis: MORRISSEY BEHIND HIS
OWN NET.
MORRISSEY GETS CHASED.
POEHLING TRIEE
THIS GETS TURNED OVER AT CENTRE.
LEHKONEN CARRIES IN.
SC
>> Kevin:
BEN CHIAROT JUMPS ON THE LOOSE
PUCK.
POKED AWAY FR ALWAYS
DRAWS A PENALT
THAT WEAK SIDE AS THE JETS
OVERLOAD ON THE PUCK SIDE. NEAL.
ANDREW COPP SCORES!
[Horn sounds] INTO HIGH ICE
LATE.
IT IS HARD TO PLUG ALL THE HOLES
ON THE POWER PLAYS.
GAME.
AND HIS 20th OF THE SEASON. COM
NUMBER THWLY OUT OF HIS OWN
ZONE.
SENDS IT IN. MID-AIR BY
KYLE CONNOR.
SCHEIFELE BACK WITH WHEELER.
FROM KYLE CONNOR.
HE'S THE FIRST MAN BACK.
GOOD DEFENSIVE STICK.
OUT THROUGH CENTRE ICE.ONK, COP.
GOAL LINE IT GOES.
STASTNY SCORES!
THE POWER PLAY,